our President Trump is reacting strongly
to one nuclear threat and saying little
about another the president says Iran is
quote playing with fire for stockpiling
uranium beyond the limits of the nuclear
deal signed in 2015 but North Korea is
still producing material for nuclear
weapons
despite US efforts including Sunday's
meeting between mr. Trump and Kim
jong-eun chip Reid is at the White House
chip how is the White House handling
these threats well president Trump's
advisors are reportedly split over how
to proceed with North Korean leader Kim
jong-un as they prepare to return to the
negotiating table some advisors
apparently are considering making
concessions as for Iran the White House
is vowing maximum pressure until Tehran
reverses course you can't let Iran have
a nuclear weapon and you can't let
certain other countries have nuclear
weapons too devastating in a new
interview president Trump continued to
push for talks with Iran even though
Tehran has said it is not ready to talk
until sanctions are lifted hopefully at
some point they'll come back and they'll
say we're gonna make a deal we'll see
what happens the president's comments
come as Iran increased its stockpile of
enriched uranium which was restricted
under the agreement mr. Trump left in
2018 the White House released a
statement yesterday vowing maximum
pressure against the regime but iran's
Foreign Minister mocked the White
House's assertion that even before the
deals existence Iran was violating its
terms writing on Twitter seriously my
friend amid rising tensions with Tehran
the u.s. faces another nuclear threat in
North Korea he Pat's the guy on the back
and gets nothing in return
Democrats continued to slam the
president's foreign policy approach but
retired Admiral sandy Winnefeld says the
president is in a better position with
North Korea now than when talks broke
down earlier this year he has everything
to gain if he can get a deal across the
table with Kim jong-un that actually
works and denuclearize North Korea as
for Iran Winnefeld says their actions
put them on a path to having enough
uranium to get their first nuclear
weapon but that would take at least
another year I think the difference
between a
and North Korea is a matter of
personality of the two regimes Kim
jong-un sees an opportunity to bond with
the president and potentially use him
and the Iranians are not so willing to
compromise when Affeldt also says the
Trump administration needs to be very
careful not to provoke open conflict
with Iran as for the possibility of a US
military attack on Tehran the president
said in his Fox News interview quote
hopefully we don't have to do anything
Gayle all right chip thank you very much